occasionally I find myself at odds with
other gamers while they spent their
childhoods with the original PlayStation
or the Super Nintendo I was still
spending all of my time on the PC as
soon as I was able to make a computer go
in the 90s my dad made sure I got stuck
into King's Quest Diablo and
rollercoaster tycoon
when other kids were racing in Mario
Kart with friends or uncovering the
horrors of Silent Hill I was building
grand cities and 15 of South's
and Age of Empires most of my non-school
hours were spent with euros of Might and
Magic 3 whether I was building maps
playing through a campaign or cracking
into the hotseat merge with my little
brother
PCs been my platform of choice for 23
years now but now that I'm past my years
of playing putt-putt goes to the moon I
can tell you why first up I was a very
shy kid who grew up into a fairly
introverted adult and although I know
where they can go both ways I've always
seen consoles is more of a social place
sort of system whereas PC has been a
solo escape even now while it's awesome
to get stuck into Mario Kart 8 with
friends or family personally it just
doesn't compare to getting lost in the
thriving and narrative laced worlds of
adventure games and RPGs on PC by myself
it's an interesting thing to be spending
time in this scripts talking about the
wonder of the single-player experience
when the giant publishers are so heavily
pushing game is to embrace social gaming
it was most apparent during this year's
e3 where almost every gaming experience
from assassin's creed that the division
is being crushed on gamers as they
played with your friend steel Sony even
came out to say that 95% of PlayStation
floors are connected to the Internet I
can tell you my original fad ps3 has
probably spent all of 95 minutes
connected to the internet and all of
those were to install updates 83 is
typically a console oriented show though
so the big social push makes sense on
the solo side of the spectrum there's
something nice about the breadth of
single-player experiences offered on
see it's web point-and-click adventure
gaming was born and bred taking the rich
narratives of books and movies and
making them into interactive game worlds
the PC took the very social
pen-and-paper
RPGs like Dungeons & Dragons and made
the Magnificent solo experiences like
folders gate and Planescape torment
while eventually social gamers could
have multiplayer experiences in Diablo
and Neverwinter Nights to these games
also let me have my RPG experiences the
way I generally like to take them that
is alone not only that but now we have
distribution platforms on PC to
recognize that some of us don't care for
achievements all being tied to Steam or
origin to playoff games good old games
and GamersGate of both doing a great job
of enabling digital purchases while
still letting your games be yours no
client to log into no DRM
no necessity to make sure your online
whilst they go go on and on about the
enjoyment and wonder involved in
cracking into a game by oneself I'll
move on to something that I think it's
probably a more widely shared reason for
PC preference precision I'm gonna start
this off by saying I freaking suck at
shooters with the gamepad I have had
barely any experience Android as its
show so now you know that up front I can
say that the control scheme and
flexibility of a keyboard and mouse is
are much better at least for me and a
lot of my friends there's a certain
precision that you can get with a mouse
that the controller is still yet to
emulate the struggle for strategy games
to find a comfortable chrome on consoles
is a pretty good testament to that aside
from that even though controllers like
the ps4 new jewel shop full feel
incredible and a super optimized for
comfort and intuitiveness I'd still
rather have the 103 keys on my keyboard
as opposed to the 16 buttons on a
controller
yeah I actually counted all the keys on
my keyboard for that one
it was a fulfilling experience anyway
last sup I'll let you know about my
favorite and probably a lot of people's
favorite thing about the PC the game
selection we live in the age of
multi-platform games and that's only
going to become more prevalent in my
opinion so I personally don't think that
exclusives matter all that much
what does matter an awful lot is that
the PC is fairly easy to develop for not
as easier as cheap as developing for
mobile but it's certainly up there as
the platform of choice for most indie
devs so maybe you're into indie games
and maybe you're not but for the few
that catch your eye or mine you're going
to want to have a PC to play them on I'm
talking steam early access with great
games that are still an alpha like Daisy
and all the offerings under Sora and
indeed EB alongside indie is the sheer
diversity of titles you can find on PC
from almost every genre theme and
gameplay focus imaginable
you've got games as complex as
civilization room turtle war Starcraft 2
and dota 2 next to things like the
longest journey the Sims and goat
simulator and all of these games live
happily next to your Call of Duty's and
Assassin's Creed's and there's no such
thing as new backwards compatibility as
even old titles have found a home on
sites like good old games even more
importantly they will actually make sure
the games run on your new system there's
something wonderfully nostalgic about
the idea that as my producer puts it
your childhood will always be accessible
whether it's the fact that steam now
houses all the spy Fox Freddy fish and
plethora of humongous entertainment
games that my brother and I devout as a
kid all that just a month ago I found
myself seriously tucking into the
original rollercoaster tycoon
speaking of which PC is the only couple
that weren't just play your old games
but also allow them to look even better
on your presumably far more powerful
computer let me know if any of my
thoughts resonated with you and most
importantly what is your platform of
choice if you don't want the hassle of
PC building or think it's all too
expensive then I'd recommend you check
out some of the great introductory
features on PC gaming which you can find
all over GameSpot right now that is it
for me today as always please do leave
me all your thoughts and feelings in
that commenting section and I'll join
you again next week